hey guys Justin here with a GameSpot
news update new head of Xbox Phil
Spencer says that the recent uproar
around the Xbox one controversy last
summer has hurt him personally
Spencer's comments come in response to
the controversy surrounding the Xbox
one's original announcement which
included a 24-hour check-in requirement
and DRM that prevented used game sales
Spencer has since acknowledged that some
of the Xbox one policy decisions
announced last summer and later reversed
were wrong during a podcast with
Microsoft's Larry Major Nelson herb
Spencer said I believe in why this
company builds products it's one of the
reasons why the whole thing around last
summer with Xbox kind of hurt me
personally so much because I know we
build Xbox for the right reasons we
didn't completely communicate it the
right way some of the decisions maybe
didn't land or weren't the right
decisions and we changed some of those
but this is a company that has the
resources to really do things that
change the world
despite the rocky start the Xbox one has
seen strong sales in the new year
bolstered by the release of the
microsoft exclusive titanfall and a
number of price drops in game packets
later this week we'll have NPD numbers
so we'll know exactly how well the Xbox
one did last month so stay tuned to game
spot.com
for even more Xbox one news